[Musik]
in den schulzimmern bleibt es still die
leinwände in den kinos sind schwarz
restaurants und bars sind leer
lea ist ausnahmsweise auch unser tisch
auf dem sich sonst die bücher unserer
gäste starten denn das buch zur corona
krise ist noch nicht geschrieben
überhaupt ist nichts mehr wie es war zb
sprechen wir hinter plexiglas wenden
wir wollen heute gemeinsam über diese
neue lage der menschheit nachdenken und
ich freue mich sehr dass sie zu schauen
und ich freue mich dass wir hier im
studio begrüßen dürfen
tanja krones sie ist medizin ethikerin
mitglied der nationalen ethikkommission
im bereich humanmedizin und ethikerin am
unispital zürich und bei uns im studio
ist eduard kaeser ist philosoph und
physiker vielen bekannt von seinen
kommentaren aus der nzz und bei uns
begrüße ich auch daniel binswanger
kreuzung leiter beim onlinemagazin
republik herzlich willkommen
danke schön herr binswanger sie haben
bereits ende februar einen text verfasst
in der republik mit dem titel die
gedanken pest und haben gesagt die große
gefahr ist dass unser denken von diesem
virus infiziert wird ist das eingetreten
ich glaube es hängt ein bisschen davon
ab was man unter infiziert werden
versteht es ist ganz klar dass wir nun
messen sind von dieser notlage dass wir
alle gedanken darauf talenten möglichst
gut über die runden zu kommen das ist ja
auch vollkommen richtig so
ich glaube von infektion könnte man dann
reden wenn wir die ängste die du
natürlich entstehen vielleicht auch zorn
aggressionen ressentiments anfangen
auf diese ganzen probleme zu projizieren
oder wenn wir versuchen der situation
sind zu geben mit schämen oder mit
erzählungen die hier nichts zu suchen
haben und diese gefahr besteht
ich glaube da müssen wir wachsam bleiben
bisher habe ich aber den eindruck wir
machen das nicht so schlimm
über diese metaphern die entstehen
können sprechen die gleich noch frau
kohn ist wie schätzen sie das ein das
denken infizieren klingt das für sie
fast ein bisschen sehr harmlos
angesichts der tatsache was passiert
wenn unser körper infiziert wird das
medizinerinnen ich glaube es ist ganz
wichtig dass wir natürlich auch als
mediziner nur menschen sind und dass uns
das natürlich auch betrifft das wir
schauen müssen dass der fokus der auf
corona ist und wichtig ist um zu schauen
dass wir die menschen gut versorgen
wie es dann zu viel raum einnimmt dass
es sozusagen raum einnimmt dem wir auch
für andere patientin für das
gesundheitswesen haben dass wir da auch
zu stark fokussieren auf diese fragen
das ist glaube ich ein ganz wichtiger
gedanke der gerade heute auch wirklich
wichtig ist
sie herr keser haben in einem interview
mit sf kultur dass man auch nachlesen
kann auf unserer website gesagt man
müsste mit dem unbekannten unbekannten
rechnen ich muss ehrlich gesagt sagen
mich hat diese neue situation komplett
unerwartet und unvorbereitet getroffen
haben sie dann mit diesem unbekannten
unbekannten wirklich gerechnet in dieser
weise nein eindeutig nicht ich habe
natürlich auch eher an eine abstraktere
abgehobene situation gedacht weil man
schon lange in verlagen
wissenschaftlichen künstlichen
intelligenz kreisen von diesen und
anderen spricht also man konstruiert
systeme die ein sozusagen entweichen
nicht mehr zu den themen verständnis
unserer unseren horizont übersteigt also
leistung heute dann bei den bei diesen
systemen eben von anderen an uns zu
sprechen
und natürlich ist das ohnehin ein
problem in der ganzen wissenschaft
sie haben ja immer modelle oder
korrigieren und paradigmen das ist wie
eine lichtquelle und im schein diese
lichtquelle suchen sie das ist erinnert
mich an den witz des betrunkenen der
anschluss sucht nicht nur im schein der
straßenlampe das schlusslied nicht dort
der liegt außerhalb im schatten und so
geht die wissenschaft natürlich
versuchen viele dort suchen wir eben
nach lösungen im schein einer theorie
und das ist auch richtig so wo sollte
man sonst suchen aber das bewusstsein
dass da eben ein schatten ist ein
schatten der in begrüßte wird je mehr
man weiß dieses bewusstsein sollte uns
allmählich eben dämmen ich trank das
meinte ich eigentlich mit und ananas
also liegt dieses corona virus im
schattenbereich oder lag es im schatten
bereit
das virus war ja schon lange bekannt
also die familie diese corona virus geht
schon länger und man wusste da es ja
auch das umständen ausbrechen konnte was
überrascht was auch nicht überrascht ist
eben diese plötzliche ausbruch ich also
ich war mit um noch mal auf jede frage
zu antworten ich war überhaupt nicht
vorbereitet ich habe es erwartet aber so
ist es halt nicht mal eine
erwartungshaltung und plötzlich trifft
sie ein also ich bin auf dem falschen
fuß erwischt
jetzt haben sie selber auch schon gesagt
man oder sie auch herr binswanger man
beginnt eben wie sich sachen zusammen zu
reimen man kommt in die welt der
metaphern man versucht erklärungsmuster
zu finden oft stimmen die überhaupt
nicht manchmal helfen sie uns um
schicksalsschläge zb besser vielleicht
überwinden zu können aber susan sontag
auf die jetzt sehr viel verwiesen worden
ist auch sie haben auch sie verwiesen
hat 1977 diesen es sei geschrieben
krankheit als metapher später dann aids
als metapher und in diesem kontext sagt
sie es ist ganz gefährlich wenn wir
beginnen die krankheit aus etwas zu
sehen was wir uns selber zuzuschreiben
haben eine metapher dafür dass sie
irgendetwas verdrängt haben oder so
ähnlich was genau ist das problem mit
diesen metaphern uns auch mit dieser
fast schon metaphern epidemie diesem
moment gibt es kaum probleme in einer
solchen situation ist natürlich immer
dass nach einem sündenbock das nach
schuldigen gesucht wird und ich glaube
wir sind hier in einer ganz neuen
situation denn
die epidemien diesen sonntag bis handelt
hat also insbesondere eben syphilis und
unterfahren ihr zweites buch aids da
geht es das sind sexuell übertragbare
krankheiten primär und dass wir da
natürlich dann sofort in einem bereich
das schuh zuschreibung sind das war
insbesondere bei der aids epidemie ganz
ganz viel land das es waren
hauptsächlich eben in einer ersten phase
homosexuelle und heroinabhängige wegen
den spitzen
betroffen waren von der epidemie da
wurde dann natürlich sofort mit massiven
schon zuschreibungen operiert nicht
heute sehen wir was nun corona anbelangt
natürlich in einer vollkommen anderen
situation und bisher kann ich eigentlich
auch nicht feststellen dass diese formen
der stigmatisierung nun sein problem
werden allerdings nicht wir haben die
amerikanische regierung insbesondere den
amerikanischen präsidenten der nun ganz
stark versucht den corona virus als
chinesischen virus zufrieden wir haben
die chinesische regierung die in
analoger weise und zurück schlägt das
sind natürlich sehr sehr wichtige
akteure also wir sehen dass diese
schemata der bewältigung weiterhin
vorhanden sind und wir sollten wirklich
darauf hin dass das nun nicht so ein
erklärungsmodell ist das natürlich
vollkommen absurd und krankheit ist ja
eigentlich nie ein biologisches
physiologisch vermeiden können das ist
ein über die biologie natur technologie
und in solchen bereichen ist natürlich
sind metaphern eigentlich fast
unentbehrlich und im übrigens ist ja die
medizin seit alters voller metaphern
also zum teil sind ja auch medizinische
theorien eigentlich ausgebaute
raffiniertere laboriert
die medizingeschichte erst in eine
geschichte von metaphern ist also eine
frühere vor dem motto crime theorie eine
frühe vor der keine theorie gebrauchte
metapher war zum beispiel die metapher
die vergiftung des anstecken sein jasmer
nicht mal dass ein jammer dass uns also
ein dampf oder vielleicht auch
flüssigkeiten die uns vergiften
das war bis ins bis zu koch und pastor
war dass das paradigma der im grunde die
infektions bekämpfung und die dieses mal
dieses jahr ein bild nicht mal das ruft
ja nach massnahmen praktischen maßnahmen
außen man muss zum beispiel aderlass
nicht weit also das giftige zeug raus
aus dem körper nicht mal oder eben auch
die an die frische luft damit die
giftigen dämpfe raus raus stürmen also
eine metapher dies zählt wichtig im
denken über den menschlichen körper
ich glaube es hat eine sinnsuche die wir
immer mit medizin überwunden haben das
ist das ist so und medizin geschichtlich
ist es schon so dass man sagen kann das
durchaus infektion also das was da kommt
was da passiert ist durchaus immer auch
schon wenn sie sagt und was neues ich
würde sagen ja aber auch irgendwo nein
weil diese suche nach sündenböcken das
kennen wir der medizingeschichte sehr
gut und gerade was infektionen angeht
hat man immer gesucht entweder in
erklärungen in metaphern aber durchaus
auch in gruppen also diese phänomene
gruppenbezogener freundlichkeiten die
kennt man ihn eine beziehungsgeschichte
sind mut dass das opferrituale gemacht
worden sind dass man gesagt hat die
jüdische mitbürger sind schuld an einer
infektion und da ist es ja gerade so
wichtig gewesen dass menschen wie zum
beispiel rudolf virchow gemerkt haben
dass hat ganz viel mit sozialer lage zu
tun das hat ein ganz anderer faktoren zu
tun und das zu verstehen dass metaphern
passieren ist uns wichtig aber auch
diese sozusagen in einem guten sind zu
werden guten sinn daran zu sehen und zu
sagen es geht um solidarität und eben
nicht um diese suche von sündenböcken
also dass ich bin ganz froh dass die
leute nur klopapier kaufen und keine
rituellen opfer morde
ja
und wiesen auf susan sontag hin
sie hat ja auch besonders auf die kriegs
mit affen auf die die militaristen mit
1000 hingewiesen
die bekämpfung das haben ja eine
einschränkung die ausrottung nicht mal
des virus und dass das ist ja heute
total im umlauf diese metapher klavier
wir müssen zurückschlagen aber das ist
ja auch noch einmal etwas interessantes
das haben sie auch betont in einem ihrer
beiträge herr keser dass sie gesagt
haben dem virus sind wir egal
und im grunde genommen könnte man fast
sagen es ist auch ein bisschen
beleidigend für den menschen der meint
alles im griff zu haben
alles kontrollieren zu können der mensch
der sich im anthropozän wen das in
diesem zeitraum in dem der mensch primär
die welt gestaltet und die welt so
aussieht wie er sie gestaltet haben
möchte und plötzlich kommt ebenso ein
virus das alles um stellt das kommt
nicht
es ist sicher wir haben recht und in
diesem sinne leben wir ja nicht die
banker prozent das habe ich auch gelesen
eigentlich immer schon im wir dort sehen
also seit anbeginn des lebens sind wir
außerdem bakterium wenn sie sowohl nicht
streiten ob jetzt jedes lebewesen sind
oder nicht aber das ist eben diese
anmaßung sei alles auf sich so dass
menschen auf sich zu beziehen
aber andererseits kann ja gar nicht
abend ist also wir können aus unserer
anthropozän trikot aus unserem antrag
bonbons muss gar nicht heraustreten
was heißt messis heraus ich kann ich
kann mich nicht in die lage eines
bakteriums versetzen
ich bin ein menschen wenn ich denke um
entspreche dann durch das eben als
angehörige meine gattung ich war es gibt
natürlich ansätze nicht
man muss sich in die perspektive des
anderen lebewesen zu versetzen und das
wird sich auch gut das wäre im übrigen
auch ein neuer ökologischer ansatz aber
auch wenn wir uns in die perspektive des
anderen lebewesen sie hineinversetzen
bleiben wir halt eben angehörige unserer
gattung
ich rede jetzt nicht von den überwindung
des menschen das wäre ein anderes thema
ich bin gerne menschen die sich in
dieser hinsicht sind halt viele dinge
die man glaube ich da sehen muss ich
glaube ein wichtiger punkt den man in
dieser kriegsrhetorik oder dem was jetzt
gerade passiert oder wie man mit dem
virus umgehen auch sagen muss wir kennen
medizin oder wir wissen dass es handeln
unter unsicherheit das schlicht ein
bisschen anders anderen anderen an und
wir wissen es gibt weil wir unter
unsicher weil menschen wenn menschen mit
unsicherheiten umgehen sei es
individuell sei es als als wissenschaft
sind es halt so phänomene die wir auch
beobachten auch massenpsychologische
phänomene sind und die beobachter mir
gerade ganz stark also dass wir auf der
einen seite eben wie sie sachen
militaristische entscheidungswege
plötzlich stärken dass menschen jetzt
sozusagen ganz massiv zu sagen so
reagieren und sagen genau so muss es
sein was wir gar nicht wissen wir werden
nachher sehr sehr viel mehr wissen und
das ist auch gut so wir werden sehr viel
daraus lernen auch ob was wir gutes
getan haben auf der anderen seite haben
wir die ganz sorglosen und ich glaube
wir müssen wirklich wie und das ist
glaube ich das demütig bekennen dass das
im moment tatsächlich nicht wissen und
versuchen mit augenmaß daran zu gehen
also weder militaristisch komplett zu
reagieren
noch komplett sorglos das sind aber
nachvollziehbaren menschliche phänomene
wie wir mit unsicherheiten umgehen
würden vielleicht wenn wir noch einmal
auf diesen gemeinsamen feiern dann gehen
können wir haben darüber gesprochen ein
feind im engeren sinne ist es nicht wir
werden eben nicht angegriffen oder
attackiert aber das gemeinsame das darin
liegt ist ja eigentlich schon
interessant es gibt viele die sagen es
ist problem also das resultat ist im
moment gerade das dass wir den eindruck
haben die globalisierung ist zu weit
gegangen und wir müssen die
globalisierung wieder eindämmen wir
sehen auch china das plötzlich irgendwie
schutzzölle noch steigert auf einem
schutzanzug oder sachen zurück behält
oder die usa die deutschen impfstoff
beim aufkaufen wollte aus eine die
globalisierung die ein stück weit
passiert gleichzeitig sind wir extrem
voneinander abhängig aber wir sind alle
im gleichen boot bezüglich dieses virus
was denken sie herr binswanger was hat
das für auswirkungen bezüglich unseres
verhältnisses zur globalisierung
es ist sicher eine ganz massive in
fragestellungen mobilisieren wir sehen
ist ja alle grenzen sind jetzt wieder
dicht
wie die längerfristige was die
längerfristigen folgen seien war nicht
dass es sehr schwierig darüber zu
spekulieren man kann sicherlich sagen
das supranationale organe ich denke da
insbesondere an die eu bis anhin keine
sehr glänzende rolle an umfassenden
solidarität gespielt haben
es wird sicher auch so sein dass nun
eben dieses psychologische moment von
wir müssen uns schützen wir müssen uns
in die augen festung zurückziehen im
falle der schweiz dass solche dinge
natürlich wieder stark zu spielen
beginnen
andererseits habe ich den eindruck dass
diese grenzschließungen einhergingen mit
dem maßnahmen zur stilllegung des
öffentlichen lebens und ich habe nicht
den eindruck nun so quasi eines
nationalistischen rückzuges sondern dass
das wahrgenommen wird als teil eines
ganzen satz von maßnahmen wo von
schulschließungen für das alltagsleben
viel viel einschneidender sind als das
nun eben nur noch bestimmte kategorien
von von franzosen und italienern die
grenzen überqueren dürfen also ich habe
stark den eindruck dass bisher dieser
dieser anti globale backlash
psychologisch nicht stattgefunden hat
dass das eine und das andere wir müssen
auch sehen wenn es denn nun so wäre dass
es zu fundamentalen veränderungen kommt
dahin gehen dass man sagt wir müssen
diese infektionsketten die um den globus
gehen können wieder unterbrechen
dann müsste man soweit zurücktreten es
würde ja nicht reichen dass man wieder
grenzkontrollen einführt dass man man
ist er ist ein vollkommen neues
wirtschaftsmodell wir müssten in einer
wir müssten
irgendwie 100 jahre zurückgehen um dass
das stattfinden wird das scheint mir
vorderhand schwer vorstellbar allerdings
gibt es einige dinge die uns noch vor
kurzer zeit schwer vorstellbar geschehen
etwas was ich auch sehr interessant
finde ist dass im moment viele sagen der
populismus wird nicht als sieger
hervorgehen
aus diesem ganzen eher jetzigen
krisensituationen jahren roche hat in
der zeit geschrieben den börsen kurse
abstürzen steigen die aktien der
sachlichkeit das fand ich eine
interessante zusammenfassung zu merken
im moment ist eigentlich die
wissenschaft diejenige die die politik
vorgibt oder die die politik in erster
linie antreibt und man hat den eindruck
dass irgendwelche kruden
verschwörungstheorien zwar natürlich
auch grassieren aber gerade eigentlich
eine neue sachlichkeit vielleicht jetzt
ihren platz finden könnte in der in der
politik es gibt neue sachlichkeit außer
ich stelle etwas nicht fest also es
findet er immer noch diese dass diese
skepsis gegenüber wissenschaft ist ja
immer noch vorhanden es gibt jetzt nicht
die griechen ereignet jetzt gibt es die
viren nicht wahr
also haben sie die wirkliche
festgestellt ich den eindruck in den
letzten jahren sind die globes war ich
leute in amerika in den fox news und so
was die über die über die wieder nur
bakterien zählen auch trump hat sich von
diesen von diesen leuten natürlich
infizieren lassen buchstäblich also die
die harmlosigkeit bis vor kurzem war ein
beraters ordnung zumindest bei vielen
politikern und ist sie immer noch und
wenn man nun eben die wissenschaft
fragte da ist immer die eigentlich die
haltung bei vielen leuten ja ihr
wissenschaftler sachlichkeit
fachlichkeit gebt uns doch jetzt mal
eine eindeutige antwort sagt uns doch
jetzt bitte wann ist sozusagen die
abflacht der abflacht punkt der kurve
erreicht
wann gibt es ein nein an dem iran als
mittel sagt uns doch dass mitte und die
wissen
schafft das ist natürlich eigentlich das
charakteristikum kann nicht antworten
sie kann keine eindeutigen antworten
geben und das wird dann unter umständen
fatale weise so interpretiert dass man
hat anders worten suchen das war man
antworten bei dummköpfen nicht mal bei
ideologen und was weiß ich immer klar
ihr kommen viele dinge zusammen nicht
dass sie sündenbock problematik denn da
haben wir ja ein deutlicher und einfach
ganz generell es ist immer schwierig für
menschen in den verschiedenen kontexten
mit wahrscheinlichkeit wir sehen jetzt
bei der glamour frage wie sehen es bei
wirtschaftlichen entwicklungen und hier
kann es ganz gut was potentiell um leben
und tod geht
bei der frage wie verhalten wir uns
jetzt rational also machen wir
beispielsweise eben ein absolutes
ausgehverbot dann haben wir eine
eindeutige situation oder sagen wir wenn
wir mit den anstand kunz
wahrscheinlichkeiten diszipliniert und
rational umgehen dann ist es besser wir
tun das nicht und können wir das der
bevölkerung zu und das heißt brauchen
wir schwarz weiß szenarien die nie die
optimalen sind oder können wir eben an
einen punkt kommen wo die breite masse
der leute mit mit wahrscheinlichkeiten
und dann auch mit wissenslücken umgehen
kann man mir haben dass er in den
akutesten alltäglichen problem jetzt ist
es halt das risiko verständnis das
risiko verständnis bevor etwas
eingetreten ist und nachher und das
osttor geständnis nur darum geht es ja
eben das kann man sich genauso wie im
bett hin das ist eine sehr schöne
metapher mit dem wetter ich meine wenn
es elfmeter sagt 50 prozent
wahrscheinlichkeit für regen dann ist es
halt das verständnis was viele menschen
haben 50 prozent der zeit und es ist
eben so dass wir ganz oder gar nicht
regnen aber wir wissen es wir wissen es
tatsächlich als nachher und man muss nur
sozusagen das verhalten danach
adjustieren wir versuchen die zukunft zu
berechnen wie max weber gesagt hat um
sie zu beherrschen
das heißt aber nicht wenn man ein risiko
berechnen kann dass es dann auch
eintritt oder das ist halt das was man
verstehen muss so funktioniert eben
die wissenschaftler glauben nicht mehr
an auch die komplexe es ist also die
wissenschaft hat sich ja heute meistens
mit komplexen system zu tun und da ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit abschätzung die
statistische prognose eigentlich
unumgänglich also aber notorisch es ist
ein notorischer weise haben wir alle
schwierigkeiten mit dem
wahrscheinlichkeit ich sage das als
mathematiker auch ich habe selber auch
probleme mit wahrscheinlichkeit ich kann
natürlich schon gewisse szenarien
wahrscheinlich war wahrscheinlich sehr
theoretisch durchrechnen aber das sind
eben szenarien und das wissenschaftliche
denken ist ein denken das hängt an
bedingungen
das sagt unter diesen diesen diesen
diesen diesen diesen bedingungen
geschieht das und das und das nun im
labor ist das relativ einfach da man
nicht mal im land ist werde ich denke
jetzt an klassische laborsituation da
kann man immerhin die bedingungen noch
kontrollieren und steuern
aber stellen sie sich jetzt eben eine
kleine gesellschaft die die schweiz vor
nicht weil die hängt von sehr vielen
parametern ab die man gar nicht unter
kontrolle hat und wie soll man jetzt da
eben auch eine verlässliche prognose
anstellen nicht das ist alles richtig
ich wollte nur auf den punkt vorhin raus
und dann den würde ich glaube ich
trotzdem festhalten auch wenn sie
natürlich zu recht jetzt sind die in die
usa blicken und und noch einmal auf
andere phänomene da hinweisen dass wir
in der schweiz schon auffällt dass man
sich im moment extrem auf die
wissenschaften bin sieht auch in der
politik und die personen die man im
moment vor allem anhört die auftauchen
die nachrichtensendungen sind
epidemiologen in deutschland ist es das
robert koch institut das mit seiner
zeitlichen pressekonferenz tausende
zehntausende hunderttausende vor die
bildschirme lockt die leute wollen jetzt
taten und sie hören ein stück weit schon
auf die wissenschaft in einer art und
weise die ich zb den eindruck habe beim
klimawandel ist das noch nicht
eingetreten da weigern wir uns so ein
bisschen die daten wirklich wahrzunehmen
ich möchte diesen positiven bild
ich möchte es relativieren ich teile
ihre feststellung nicht dass es findet
so etwas wie eine epidemiologische
aufklärung statt nur die frage die sie
aufgeworfen haben was ist nun
gewissermaßen das politische
leistungspotenzial unter dem stichwort
populismus es ist natürlich nicht so
dass wenn die börsenkurse sinken dass
dann die gewissheiten der kurs der
vernunft steigt also wenn wir das letzte
mal ausliegt börsenkurse dramatisch
gesunken sind das war bei der
finanzkrise und die folge war die tea
party bewegung und letztlich kramp und
auch in europa sind sehr sehr viele
hässliche politische dinge seither
geschehen
wir stehen ganz am anfang was die frage
der einkleidung die man unter dem
stichwort populismus zusammenfassen kann
betrifft
das muss man erst einmal ansehen ja
worauf wodurch zeichnet sich populismus
aus einerseits das bedürfnis nach dem
starken wir sie natürlich heute in einer
situation in der das starke mann eine
größere gefahr ist als jemals in der
geschichte europas und der usa und alle
restlichen länder zeit in zeiten krieg
wir sind in einer note rechtssituation
und wir sind per definition in einer
lage in der autoritäre entgleisungen
einen ganz konkreten ähnliche gefahren
sind wenn der bundesrat nun irgendetwas
machen will was gegen alle grundsätze
und ethischen prinzipien verstehen
verstößt dann hat er dazu das recht
verdächtig ihn absolut keiner schlechten
intention und bisher macht er sehr gut
aber wir sehen in einer rechtssituation
die diese gefahr ganz ganz wir wollen
verbraucher verdenken kann und wichtig
sehr sehr viel schenken da müssen wir
sehr genau
aber ist das ist ein element also es
gibt noch andere aspekte aber riesig
dass noch klar zu sagen notrecht gilt ja
nicht es ist die außerordentliche lage
gemäss schweizer epidemien gesetz
notrecht ist damit noch nicht gemeint
aber das hat ja einen not rechtlich
richtig ja aber klar ich will dass
verstärken was sie sagen das ist
sozusagen mein ruf nach führen das ist
hat dieser dieser reaktion auf
unsicherheit und muss jetzt sagen das
menschliche wesen ist denke ich nur
logisch wie wir in der wissenschaft ja
manchmal schon sagen psychologisch wir
denken noch sicher logisch das heißt wir
gehen auch mit riesigen psychologisch
und ich sag das mal vielleicht ganz
konkret jetzt wenn ich jetzt den
impfstoff für corona kommt dann wären
wahrscheinlich sich alle menschen gegen
korona aber niemand trotzdem gegen
grippe impfen und es kann immer noch
sein
also wir unterschätzen das kennt man ja
guten mehr geschäft überschätzen
bestimmte risiken obwohl die numerisch
gar nicht stärker sind wir haben angst
vorm fliegen aber nicht alles vom
autofahren ich bin diese phänomene kennt
man eben auch dass es eben auch eine
reaktion auf das menschen was wäre das
problem in halle sich gegen korona in
denen wir nun nicht mehr gegen die
saisonale grippe dann hätten wir da eine
neue wie also sieht dass das ist jetzt
vielleicht nicht schlecht dass es halt
man muss halt immer in größeren
komplexen denken auch dass also das ist
ja eine möglichkeit wenn jetzt der
impfstoff aber sehr sehr teuer ist ich
mache jetzt mal das beispiel auch sehr
sehr teuer wäre und alle sich impfen
würden dann haben wir nachher nichts
mehr an ressourcen im gesundheitswesen
das muss auch bezahlt werden für andere
dinge und es kommt vielleicht nachher
mehr krankheit raus also das ist halt
genau das nicht dass man halt nicht mit
risiken und mit diesen gefahren halt die
das denken offizieren manchmal dann
irrational umgeht im nachhinein johanna
weiß man immer besser naja also
nachhinein ist man schon rational nicht
sagen aber wenn er in der situation ist
gibt es eben die alle diese ich würde
nicht mal von ihrer nationalität
sprecher zufolge foyers dies
rationalität also man hat zeit ein
fehlverhalten bei sonst normal
verstandes tätigkeiten also bei durchaus
geistig gesunden disposition denken sie
haben die den papier kauf nicht mal also
alle kaufen kaufen klopapier ja warum
eigentlich gibt es einen grund
illusionen peter control also einen
menschen versuchen in einen also
uneindeutigkeit wo es kein muster gibt
oder das erkennen ist irgendwas ein
muster reinzubringen das kennt man aus
eine dieser nationale sicherheit im
grunde genommen ich stelle mir folgendes
experiment experiment formenkreis
experiment angenommen wie ein laden
verkauft nun sehr viel sagen wir fußball
zauber nicht wahr und die leute kaufen
wie wild fußpilz salbe ich würde fast
davon ausgehen dass dann früher oder
später eine fußpilz krise eintreten geht
man kauft einfach und weiß nicht warum
die leute fühlen sich angesteckt also
fußpilz vielleicht vermutet man ja gibt
es da eine versteckte fußballs
ansteckung pdf gebiet keine epidemie
nicht war aber gibt es da irgendwo etwas
im untergrund dass da uns in lietzow
nicht nur das daran unseren füßen herum
lag und dann geht man in den laden kauft
fußball sauber sei das sind eben ich
fühlte dass nicht irrational in seinem
distrikt dieser nationalität also so
ähnlich man kauft klopapier weil es kein
klopapier mehr gibt wenn man auch
klopapier weil man denkt alle brauchen
club ist ja unglaublich ist muss doch
einen grund geben nicht doch ein
psychologisches einem massenphänomen
glaube ich ja ein psychologisches
massenphänomen dass es im moment auch
geben da fragte ich auch kurz zu
sprechen kommen möchte sind diese
unglaublich vielen kartons und videos
die im moment gerade kursieren die leute
machen natürlich auch viele späße jetzt
über dieses corona virus wir wollen uns
ein paar solche späße anschauen hier zum
beispiel gefesselte kinder am boden
während des home office die mutter kann
arbeiten die kinder sind geknebelt oder
ein anderes bild die schlacht bei micro
2020 nach christus die hamsterkäufe die
um sich greifen oder auch diverse bilder
die zeigen was es noch für alternative
geben könnte wenn die schutzmasken
ausgehen
und es gibt natürlich auch ganz viele
videos die im moment ein gedreht werden
und hochgeladenes video wurde in zürich
gedreht und vom onlinemagazin ist die
verbreitete schaut kurz rein
[Musik]
das britische ok sowie von gestern
denn schwimmen weltcup in chaux de fonds
cashflow
der vorstoß des giftes dorfdisco
statistiken rocky iv liest du es
egoistisch
[Musik]
zuber
die
[Musik]
wir machen ich glaube wir sind jetzt das
vom allerwichtigsten wir müssen jetzt
irgendwie psychologische überlebens
strategien entwickeln ich finde das
funktioniert auch sehr gut
beispielsweise dass plötzlich leute
gezielt anrufen weil sie nicht mehr
treffen können also dass das das muss
man sowieso nicht eine verabredung der
beiden märkte leute die nicht sonst nie
angerufen ruf mich haben für ein langes
gespräch mit mir glaube ich witze das
gehört in dieser form der entwicklung
von sozialer wärme unter bedingungen des
social business und das ist eine sehr
gute sache
was dieses video anbelangt hatte ich
jetzt den eindruck das ist vielleicht
eine etwas angewandte botschaft enden
also der songtext ist großartig aber der
film bestand er daraus dass da alle
diese jugendlichen draußen rumhängen ja
was ist das video ist jetzt doch schon
glaube ich ungefähr zehn tage alt das
ist ein bisschen wohl noch nehme mal an
jetzt während bewerten auch ein bisschen
komisch aber dass man da gibt es ja eine
milliarde paar spiele und ich das gehört
für mich also dass man jetzt irgendwie
einfallsreich und montiert und ich
glaube das ist sehr wichtig schon sagt
überlebensstrategie ich meine guten
grund gibt es clowns in kinder spitälern
und wir wissen humor ist wirklich
wirklich wichtig und damit umzugehen
warum also auch noch einen allgemeinen
philosophischen standpunkt
hereinzubringen humor ist ja eigentlich
immer mit einer anderen perspektive
verbunden also wir lachen ja weil da
plötzlich eine ganz andere
gesichtspunkte auf dauer der witz beruht
ja dann auch nicht wahr
wir haben da ein phänomen und plötzlich
beleuchtet man das phänomen von einer
ganz anderen seite aus einer ganz
anderen perspektive
und das ist natürlich auch hier so wohl
nicht mal gegen diesen diesen ernst
diesen realen ernst nicht gibt es immer
noch eine andere perspektive
man kann eben spiele die schon gehen man
kann hoffen
ganz andere weisen mit dieses
ernsthaften lage umgehen und das ist
sogar wichtig wenn dann politik wenn
dann politiker daher kommen und eben
ernst diese lage eben auch übel betonen
ich denke zum beispiel an unseren
gesundheitssektor und kanton bern stab
beim kanton bern die nun schon gestern
war das von einer welle spricht nicht
gerade haben uns zurollt also eine welle
extrapoliert wahrscheinlich von vom
kanton uhr sahen hier wo es fühlt sich
eine achtfache achtfache vervielfachung
der fälle gegeben hat haben das mag ja
sein aber es ist eine farce auch eine
falsche metapher die welle an
infektionen sind keine wellen ist das
sind her der die sich miteinander
verknüpfen das wäre wahrscheinlich die
angepasste oder die bessere metapher und
bei welle da denkt man ja an die alle
tsunami und das so ist gleich das
empfinden der menschen oder dass man
muss das nicht noch nicht nur türen aus
als verantwortlich an
verantwortungsvoller
gesundheitspolitiker nichterhalt das
finde ich eine wirklich ein was
fahrlässige verwendung von metaphern in
der politik in diesen bahnen
das würde ich gerne ganz konkret werden
und auch über die situation in der
schweiz sprechen konkreter noch in
krankenhaus sie frau krones sind vom
unispital zürich sind da
medizinethikerin wenn man sich das jetzt
vorstellt wenn das so weitergeht und
situationen eintreffen werden wie
vielleicht in italien dann werden wir
nicht um eine sogenannte regierung
herumkommen man wird möglicherweise
nicht mehr alle menschen behandeln
können
das stellt enorme ethische fragen was
passiert war genau und wie entscheiden
sie also moment ist es ganz wichtig um
das anzuknüpfen dass wir im moment ja
auch sagen wenn solange es so ist es
jetzt versuchen wir die möglichst guten
entscheidungswege und auch prinzipien
die wir vertreten auch jetzt zu
vertreten patientenautonomie ist immer
noch wichtig in zeiten von corona und
solidarität transparenz ist wichtig und
wir müssen das sozusagen anpassen also
wir haben im moment die situation dass
wir versuchen das wirklich zu stärken
auch die solidarität zwischen den
spitälern
dass wir wissen jetzt wo sind freie
betten also dass wir das wirklich
stärken und das wir aber immer einen
plan b ist nicht nur in der tasche haben
und c sondern auch voraus planen das ist
glaube ich das was ganz ganz wichtig ist
eigentlich letztlich geht es auch darum
die triage auch zu vermeiden und medizin
das möchte ich ganz ist mir ganz wichtig
zu sagen findet nicht vor allen dingen
im unispital anstatt sondern befindet
vor allen dingen war es ärzten statt in
pflegeheimen das ist vielmehr was die
bevölkerung dafür sorgt dass und das
ganz ganz wichtig miteinander auch
zuschauen zu kooperieren und also triage
vermeiden wir heißen ja auch nicht erst
die zahlen so hoch schnellen zu lassen
was man wirklich nicht mehr alle
behandeln kann ja ich man erstmal zum
beispiel wahl eingriffe aussetzen später
oder sind wir jetzt dran genau dass wir
und da ist natürlich auch ein augenmaß
gefragt
wir sind ja auch verpflichtet jetzt
schon wahl eingriffe das ist jetzt den
weg des kantons zürich auch vom
bundesrat mit veranlasst richtigerweise
nach dem pandemieplan des bundes dass
wir jetzt dringlich nicht dringliche
eingriffe verschieben
das ist das wird auch gemacht gerade das
tun wir aber natürlich ist auch der
augenmaß gefragt wie gesagt weil es
kommt drauf an wenn die krise natürlich
länger dauert wenn man eine
krebserkrankung hat zum beispiel ist es
wichtig dass die auch trotzdem
stattfinden können dass wir also nicht
nicht corona tote sagen verstärken also
dass wir jetzt nicht durch die
fokussierung auf bewohner und auf die
maximierung sozusagen der der
ausrichtung auf eine viele verknüpfte
infektionen dass wir da nicht vergessen
dass eben die medizin aus gutem grund
auch präventiv wirksam ist als ich
meinte aber auch mit der triage
verhindern
als wichtigen punkt ist dass wir hier
erst mal verhindern müssen dass menschen
die gar nicht ins spital wollen und das
betrifft ja gerade im moment die
situation dass wir darüber reden dass am
ehesten jetzt menschen betroffen sind
die also schwer betroffen sind von
corona nicht infiziert werden sondern
schwer betroffen sind die hoch betagt
sind die vielleicht schon sehr krank
sind und da ist es einerseits wichtig
und richtig dass wir sagen auch die
menschen sind extrem variabel und die
müssen wir versorgen aber es auch
wichtig zu sehen dass menschen die schon
in der situation sind vielleicht gar
nicht alle intensivmedizinischen
behandlung wollen das war vor corona so
das ist jetzt schon so und da sind wir
jetzt alle gefragt menschen also eine
patientenzentrierte medizin zu stärken
indem man wirklich auch in den heimen
in den pflegeheimen auch die hausärzte
mit ihren patientinnen und patienten die
schwer krank sind sprechen wenn sie es
nicht schon getan haben das tut man ja
auch schon vorher und sagt möchtest du
überhaupt
da würde ich da würde ich gerne ganz
konkret nachfragen jetzt wurden zahlen
im tages anzeiger heute am freitag an
dem tag an dem wir hier sitzen
publiziert da hieß es in italien ist das
durchschnittsalter der todesfälle liegt
bei 79,5 jahren
da denke ich tatsächlich an menschen in
meinem umfeld die sehr alt sind auch
menschen die ich an getroffen habe mit
dem rollator auf der straße ich habe
gefragt soll ich ihnen helfen kann ich
für sie irgendwie etwas besorgen gehen
dann können sie zu hause bleiben und
dann war die antwort nein
für mich ist das auch in ordnung ich
habe mein leben gelebt können diese
menschen den wirklich sagen ich möchte
gar nicht mehr ins krankenhaus ist nicht
die schwierigkeit dass irgendwann dann
der notarzt hat auch gerufen wird und er
dann verpflichtet ist menschen die
korona symptome haben ins krankenhaus zu
bringen und es zwangsläufig zu dieser
überlastung des gesundheitssystems
kommen wird also aus ethischer
perspektive ist es ganz ganz wichtig
jetzt schon und es gibt diese konzepte
dass wir das wir vorsorgen dass nur
derjenige oder diejenige ins spital
kommt die das will das ist wirklich ganz
zentraler punkt den wir seit 20 jahren
ganz stark machen in der medizinethik
dass wir wirklich eine gesundheitliche
vorausplanung machen und das wenn zum
beispiel ein mensch genau so wie sie
schilder mit einer lebensumstände muss
gar nicht krank sein aber wirklich sagt
ich habe wirklich mein leben gelebt ich
brauche wenn ich heute nacht friedlich
einschlafen würde würde ich das nicht
bedauern wenn man den wenn man das so
bespricht mit seinen liebsten und mit
seinem hausarzt dass das wirklich klar
ist dass man das auch verordnet
sozusagen das gibt es wir haben diese
art sich im notfall in ordnung wenn
menschen sagen sie möchten wirklich egal
man weiß nicht ob es einen trifft aber
wenn es eintrifft in der
lebenseinstellung die man hat möchte man
gar nicht mehr ins spital
dann kann man das so machen dass man
diese ärztlichen notfall anordnung
durchsetzt und dann ist es noch ganz
wichtig dass ich durch das sagen dass
wir dann aber auch in den heimen schauen
dass die palliativ care teams
niedrigschwellig geholt werden dass es
wirklich für diejenigen die das für sich
klar haben klar ist und dass man dann
aber auch richtig reagiert und das ist
möglich das tun wir schon das ist jetzt
etwas was wir schweizer
friedlich einschlafen mit dem corona
währung siemens geht ja da in erster
linie um hasen probleme ja ich glaube
wir müssen wirklich ganz konkret ja ganz
konkret also ich bin ein bisschen
vorsichtig aber ich möchte es doch sagen
als ich medizin studentin war in den
80er jahren hat der alte hat mein alter
internist internistische professor
gesagt die lungenentzündung ist ein
freund des alten mannes
also heißt eine lungenentzündung wenn
man die hat und das ist ja das was mit
corona immer in der regel passiert wenn
man die wut palliativ medizinisch
betreut
wir werden alle sterben an
lungenentzündung zu sterben ist nicht
das schlimmste ist nicht der schlimmste
tod wer das nicht möchte für die muss
man kämpfen aber für der sagt ich habe
mein leben gelebt kann man eine
lungenentzündung wirklich menschen
orientiert und hochprofessionell
palliativ betreuen und dafür machen die
palliativmediziner auch gerade noch an
alle kolleginnen kollegen in einer task
force auch heute wird ja viel von task
force geräte das klingt auch sehr
intensiv auch nochmal für alle die pläne
dass man sagt was kann man bei atemnot
tun für menschen die eben nicht mehr ins
spital wollen dass man wirklich symptome
bestmöglich bekämpfen glauben sie denn
dass hat in italien zb gefehlt dass man
menschen gar nicht erst auf die
intensivstation gelegt hat die das
vielleicht auch noch nicht mehr wohl
also es ist zumindest so dass unsere
kollegen aus italien die wirklich sehr
sehr finde ich sehr exzellente arbeit
geleistet haben jetzt uns auch helfen
mit ihren erfahrungen und in der
richtlinie der schweizer der
entschuldigung der italienischen
intensivmediziner der ethik richtlinien
stehen wirklich an zwei punkten genau
das drin was ich gerade gesagt habe
planen sie vor setzen die
patientenverfügungen um sprechen sie mit
ihrem hausarzt sagen sie was ihnen
wirklich wichtig ist tun sie das sind
zwei von den von der liste der
italienischen kollegen die gesagt haben
das ist wirklich ganz zentral
wir wollen niemandem spital am der das
nicht möchte ich mache mir ganz auch
schon gesagt ein bisschen sorge um den
generationenvertrag gerade als ich höre
junge menschen die sagen es ist
unglaublich was man von uns verlangt
auch junge unternehmen die wirklich
existenziell bedroht sind die
darum kämpfen überhaupt überleben zu
können
und die sagen da es ist jetzt wirklich
die frage wie machen wir die große
güterabwägung zwischen überleben vor
allem eben von auch älteren
bevölkerungsgruppen versus ökonomisches
überleben um zugleich ältere menschen
die sagen was soll das jetzt vielleicht
wird man uns baut einmal ermuntern dass
wir uns jetzt da irgendwie
patientenverfügung zulegen sollen nun
nicht die spital wenden da belegen
verschreckt dieser generation vertrag
wie schätzen sie das ein herr bin zwar
mehr gerät der gerade unter druck ja wir
geraten gewissermaßen ein objektives
dilemma obwohl es ja auch so ist das
nicht nur nun hochbetagte patienten
betroffen sind auch von schweren
verläufen
also es ist ja nun nicht so dass wir
alle probleme lösen würden wenn es eben
diese patientenverfügungen vom sehr sehr
alten menschen gäbe es ist sicherlich
ein aspekt aber dass man in einem sehr
komplizierten abwägungs dilemma drin ist
weil es natürlich richtig ist dass wir
nicht für die nächsten zwei jahre unsere
wirtschaftliche aktivität auf null
herunterfahren können also dass man da
einen richtig kalibrierten mittelweg
wird gehen müssen wo sich wieder die
schwierigkeit ergibt dass es zehn jahren
sind die mit bestimmten
wahrscheinlichkeiten bewertet sind
das ist das ist richtig ich glaube der
test wird kommen an dem punkt wo eben
dass das gesundheitssystem am oberen
rand steigt ja meine vermutung wäre dass
es dann eine ganz starke solidarität
gibt denn dann wird das betroffene
hatten geben dann wird es die eigene
großmutter sein dann werden dass im
weiteren bekanntenkreis leute seien aus
der eigenen altersgruppe
die großmutter von sehr nahestehenden
leuten sein
ich leide dann reden wir über etwas ganz
harmlos und dann bin ich sehr sehr
zuversichtlich dass es eine ganz klare
ethische priorität in ordnung gibt die
tragen wird und das ist der schutz von
leben und wenn wir von güterabwägung
sprechen haben wir natürlich vor allem
immer die materiellen güter im blick ist
alles wie steht es dann mit dem
geistigen güten nicht an also mit den
kulturgütern
ich stelle schon jetzt fest natürlich
ist es ganz wichtig dass die die
gesundheit das physische problem nicht
weil ich möchte gerne geschont bleiben
ich möchte auch gerne unter umständen da
mal geimpft werden ich möchte überleben
kurz so gut also einfach darwinistischen
biologisch physisches problem arbeit
ich denke jetzt in diesem zusammenhang
an die vielen kleinen kulturschaffenden
in der schweiz die in diesem sinne ihre
existenz basis nicht gedacht vielleicht
nicht gerade verliehen
viele schon aber bedroht sehen und die
natürlich auch für eine art gesundheit
verantwortlich sind dass diese
gesundheit diese intellektuelle mentale
auch psychische gesundheit finde ich
eigentlich viel wichtiger als die
wirtschaftliche gesundheit die jetzt
überall natürlich im vordergrund steht
und die man eben auch in die waagschale
wirft bei der güterabwägung das geistige
nicht halt das kommt wirklich zu kurz
und auch in der interviewzone vorplanen
der bundesrat meines wissens hat der
bundesrat noch nichts an strategien oder
projekten verlauten lassen wie man
eigentlich diese niemand der künstlerin
selbstständig erwerbende zur seite
gesprungen werden und die wehren in der
kategorie können aber bisher glaube ich
ist das noch nicht entschieden
aber das neue und güterabwägung ja
einfach noch schwieriger oder wir haben
gesundheit menschen leben die haben
ökonomische überleben prosperität das
wird ganz ganz ganz viel betreffen wird
extreme folgen haben um sie haben diese
frage so zu sagen dass des geistigen
reichtum der verlustig gehen könnte ja
ich meine das ist ja das was ein dilemma
ausmacht wie man es richtig verstanden
hat dilemmas immer schmerzhaft im
dilemma kann man nicht sozusagen raus
kommen ohne sich die finger schmutzig zu
machen das ist ja das ist das was in dem
dilemma im google ist und ich will das
noch mal aus der medizin so sogar auch
bestärken was sie beide gesagt haben es
ist ja so dass der faktor wo wir sicher
wissen dass ein extrem effekt auf
mortalität und morbidität also auf
krankheit und tod hat ist die soziale
lage also es gibt keinen kein keinen
anderen faktor den wir so gut kennen der
wirklich ein extrem effekt hat und auch
die ungleichverteilung einer
gesellschaft hat einen direkten effekt
auf morbidität und mortalität das heißt
es tatsächlich hochrelevant auch aus der
medizin ethischen perspektive und auch
für erz und ärzte die sind ja nicht nur
fürs individuum zuständig sondern wir
haben kriterien wo wir auch auf die
öffentliche gesundheit denken das heißt
wir müssen wirklich schauen dass wir
nicht durch die durch die das wind dass
wir in diesem dilemma nicht schauen dass
wir vor dass er eine verarmung haben was
letztlich dann mittelfristig dazu führen
wird dass wissen wir jetzt schon das
können und sagen würde das wird uns auch
krankheit kosten und vielleicht darf ich
das doch sagen wir haben ein system wo
wir die die vero sagt wir brauchen
universelle public health coverage also
eine juni werben healthcare it jeder
sollte versorgt sein
auch in der schweiz haben wir lücken in
der versorgung wir haben den artikel in
dem kvg das ist glaube ich 64 a
der schwarze kassen ermöglicht zu haben
ist von künstlern gesprochen man kann
auch von den taxifahrern reden
möglicherweise noch mit einem
gesicherten aufenthaltsstatus die gehen
nicht zum sozialamt und wenn die
schieflage kommen können die ihre
prämien nicht zahlen das heißt die sind
dann vielleicht nicht krankenversichert
das heißt unter der heutigen
gesetzeslage kann es sein dass die nur
eine notfallversorgung kriegen und
übrigens auch je nach kanton ihre kinder
im thurgau das heißt wir haben wirklich
phänomene die auch aus der medizin sicht
und man sagen muss das ist wirklich mut
oder hochrelevant auch für die
gesundheit auch in diese an diese sachen
zu denken
es ist ganz klar eine krise dieser größe
er fordert eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
solidarität die viel weiter geht die
viel stärker ist die viel systematischer
ist aus dass unter normalen bedingungen
stattfindet der medizinische aspekt
steht nun im vordergrund aber es ist
natürlich nicht der einzige was ist wenn
wir nun in eine ganz schwere
wirtschaftskrise hinein gehen wonach es
aussieht mit den karriereperspektiven
junger menschen
wenn das nun mehrere jahre dauert es
gibt ja auch viele ökonomische studien
die zeigen von so etwas erholt man sich
tendenziell sein ganzes leben nicht mehr
wenn man in der falschen phase gestartet
ist hat man viel schlechtere
entwicklungsperspektive und so weiter
und da möchte ich einfach eine
historische bemerkung machen
der sozialstaat ich glaube eine der ganz
großen zivilisatorischen
errungenschaften der auch zur
universellen abdeckung oder fast immer
seinen abdeckung im gesundheitssystem
geführt hat kommt aus den weltkriegen
ja es war ein anschluss an den ersten
und weltkrieg und dann während der
weltwirtschaftskrise und noch immer viel
stärker im zweiten weltkrieg aus alle
westlichen gesellschaften wirklich
seriöse sozialstaaten geschaffen haben
es war eine gesamtgesellschaftliche
solidarische antwort auf die größte
krise die die menschheit bis dato zu
bewältigen hat und natürlich ist gott
sei dank die korona krise nicht mit den
weltkrise er kriegen zu vergleichen aber
es ist seit den weltkriegen
wahrscheinlich die größte globale krise
und was wir werden leisten müssen um
darüber hinwegzukommen
das ist eine neue erfindung ein ausbau
eine substantielle verstärkung aller
sozialen system das gilt ja
wahrscheinlich auch oder erst recht wenn
wir uns die globale situation noch
einmal vor augen schauen ich muss sagen
mich beschäftigt die situation sehr wenn
man an die flüchtlingslager auch denkt
denken wir haben die menschen an den
grenzen der türkei
denken sie auch an die situation im
flüchtlingslager moria nur um ein
beispiel zu nehmen auf lesbos wir wissen
es gibt erste fälle
lesbos wenn man sich ausdenkt in diesem
flüchtlingslager leben ungefähr 20.000
menschen auf einem platz
der platz hätte für 3000 menschen und es
gibt in diesem flüchtlingslager keine
seife kann man muss sich nur einmal
ausdenken was da auf diese menschen zu
kommen wird wir blicken die auf diese
situation wenn die den horizont noch
größer machen absolut ich bin ich habe
glaube ich schon zitiert den rudolf
virchow dass wir als einer der größten
pathologen einer der der die sozial
hygiene mit in die welt gebracht hat und
der war genau derjenige der da so für
gekämpft hat dass wir genau da
hinschauen auch also das ist dass dies
die menschen sind am meisten gefährdet
und das sind auch frauen und kinder und
wenn man auf engstem raum
das war schon immer mit der tuberkulose
so das war mit dem fleck typhus wo dass
er was herr rudolph welche in
oberschlesien wo dahin geschickt worden
ist gesagt hat es ist nicht dass das
agens was er da man auch was das gehirn
hat sondern es ist die soziale lage dass
ein gefecht sein das zu enge die die
mangelnde hygiene also das ist wirklich
so wenn wir dafür einstehen und das tun
wir gott sei dank in der schweiz dass
menschenrechte und der schutz des lebens
nicht nur national gebunden ist oder an
eigenschaften gebunden ist sondern
grundlegend gilt dann dürfen wir da
nicht wegsehen und nur dass wir jetzt
nur einige fälle haben nicht daran
werden keine tests für mich ist der
umgang mit den flüchtlingen das betrifft
nicht nur die schweiz auf die
europäische union hat analoge maßnahmen
gestern bekannt geben eigentlich der
eklatanteste fall des moralischen und
politischen versagens der sich bis anhin
manifestiert hat denn die schweizerische
flüchtlingspolitik innerhalb des
schengen-raums schengen raumes war immer
beruht auf dem prinzip dass zwar
eigentlich rechtlich betrachtet
einreisende aus den angrenzenden
schengen staaten nicht ein unbedingt zu
gewähren das einreise recht hätten weil
sie ja aus einer sichere also einem
sicheren gebiet kommen und wahrheit sie
ja auch in italien frankreich oder
deutschland ihren antrag stellen können
das war absoluter konsens bis am letzten
freitag da wurde das umgestoßen und
wurde gesagt schengen/dublin erlaubt uns
ja diese leute abzuweisen
wir weisen jetzt
und wohin weisen wir sie ab wir weisen
sie ab in das am allerstärksten
versehrte gebiet europas nämlich in die
lombardei und das ist zutiefst und
solidarisch und es ist zutiefst
unethisch
natürlich muss man verständnis daran
dafür haben dass nun im kanton tessin
man auch andere sorgen hat ja wir sehen
das ja auch die eu so agiert aber es hat
man da nicht klar keine kapazitäten
geschaffen hat und gesagt hat wir stehen
wenigstens in diesem punkt unseren
lombardischen nachbarn bei das ist für
mich ja nicht klappt ist versorgen
jetzt sind gegen den rabenschwarzen
tiefen dieser krise das sind
wahrscheinlich wirklich die dinge bei
denen wir von humanitären krisen werden
sprechen müssen die ganze unglaublich
auf diese menschheit zu kommen werden
ich würde gerne versuchen zum schluss
dieses gesprächs noch auf das thema
hoffnung einzugehen und sie zu fragen du
bist der neue ist zu meinen wir könnten
aus dieser krise etwas lernen sie ist
natürlich zu früh zu fragen werden wir
etwas gelernt haben
aber es gibt auch viele die jetzt sagen
na ja wir können uns ja mal überlegen
der klimawandel vielleicht ja profitiert
jetzt gerade davon ist wird zum beispiel
nicht mehr so viel geflogen
man überlegt auch es gibt einzelne
wissenschaftler die behaupten dass die
menschen die jetzt gerettet werden die
über leben in china weil die luft besser
ist vielleicht mehr menschen sind wie
die opfer die dieses virus einem
gefordert hat gibt es anlass zu solcher
hoffnung oder finden sich einfach nur
naiv oder vielleicht ganz einig dass ich
es nicht mehr gibt dass sie also jetzt
gerade diese behauptung über china finde
ich natürlich schon etwas extravagant
dabei es gibt in vielen hoffnung man
muss eben auch fantasie entwickeln und
das ist auch gerade eine hoffnung gibt
leute werden
fantasievolle improvisatorisch
herausgefordert sowieso jetzt durch die
situation
und schon das ist ein von mir aus
gesehen ein gutes zeichen dass auch ein
gutes zeichen ist
sie haben einmal von demut gesprochen
wir lernen allmählich eine gewisse demut
jetzt gesamtprogramm gesehen und da
komme ich wieder auf das thema zurück
dass sie anfangs angesprochen haben
geben wir leben mit an den wissen
zusammen und das ist wirklich ökologisch
leben ökologisch und jetzt entdecken wir
plötzlich die rückseite der ökologie
also wir entdecken die düstere seite der
ökologie den merken plötzlich dass zu
diesen ökologie milliarden von kleinen
fächern gehören über die wir keine
kontrolle haben und irgendwie ich sagte
in diesem artikel denn diesen flächen
sind wir völlig egal
die überleben auch ohne uns doch also
die wieden brauchen
unter umständen könnten die auch
mutieren nicht weil die evolution ist
der einzigen mutations während ein
ungeheuer mutations mechanismus und
vielleicht modellen die auf eine weise
dass sie uns nicht mehr benötigen und
wie ein käse um uns konkret joachim
tröstet sie denn der gedanke dass sie
sagen es ist vielleicht gar nicht so
wichtig dass wir überleben ich meine
solche theorien
also ich möchte nicht auf in diese
richtung argumentieren
also ich bin ich bin dafür dass wir aus
menschen also dass der mensch aus
gattung bestehen bleibt und ich bin auch
nicht für diese apokalyptischen visionen
in denen der mensch nicht mehr da ist
also diese vision und kennen wir seit 40
jahren nicht als das hat ein deutscher
autor namen ich weiß nicht mehr
horstmann hat ulrich horstmann hat vor
40 jahren über das untier das und ihre
gesprochen oder geschrieben sogar und
hat frohlockt wenn der planet einmal
gereinigt sei von uns nicht wahr
also das ist nicht er selbst überhaupt
nicht meine vision wie sehen sie es
blicken sehen sie etwas position würde
ich also ja mit nietzsche halten
der mensch ist das nicht still gestaltet
hier mit unglaublichen entgleisung
potenzial und auch immer wieder mit
großartigen möglichkeiten ja also wie
die horse manche anthroposophie täter
hat mich nun auch immer nur sehr
begrenzt verführen können sie kennen das
buchen aber natürlich natürlich kann aus
jeder krise auch gutes erwachsen das
vielleicht ein neues ökologie
bewusstsein da ist natürlich die
verbindung am nächsten
ich sehe aber auch in der hinsicht ich
schon angedeutet haben wie wird sich
angesichts einer solchen
herausforderungen ihrer hoffentlich
gemeinsame bewältigung der begriff vom
gesellschaftlicher solidarität wandeln
auch da ist sehr sehr viel möglich ich
würde sagen was uns die krise
unmittelbar zeigt ist alles ganz anders
sein in guten bis alles kann ganz anders
sein
die nächsten wochen werden sehr
herausfordern sein und es wird
wahrscheinlich zu optimistischen utopien
relativ wenig konkreter anlass bestehen
aber das aus all dem sich dann auch
positives und vor allen dingen ganz
neues entwicklung kann ich glaube das
sollten wir nicht aus den augen
verlieren
ich erlaube mir mit dieser hoffnung doch
hier zu schließen
ich danke ihnen ganz ganz herzlich dass
sie da waren herr binswanger frau tonis
herr keser danke sehr für dieses
gespräch
von der panne betroffen sind bekanntlich
auch die kinder die nicht mehr zur
schule gehen können
sr s my skull hat sein angebot ausgebaut
und auch wir von den sternstunden haben
uns etwas ausgedacht nämlich einmal und
schreibwettbewerb zu einer
philosophischen frage
die teilnahmebedingungen gibt es auf der
website von srf high school
wir freuen uns auf die schlauen kinder
auf die schlauen ideen entschuldigung
der kinder nächste woche spricht ich
passat mit dem französischen star
ökonomen thomas kutschaty über die
schere zwischen
reich gegen korona musste auch die preis
verleihung des schweizer filmpreises
abgesagt werden
den preis gibt es natürlich dennoch und
auch unsere beliebte vielen kritiker
runde jetzt gleich im anschluss danke
fürs interesse bleiben sie gesund
bis bald
[Musik]